all right
in this situation mike's grabbed my
lapel let's actually go to the other
side real quick
just grab my lapel here i want to get
away from this hand who knows what he's
up to with it he can have a weapon in
all kinds of bad stuff so i'm going to
move to the outside
now as i do this i'm going to bring my
arm over the top if mike's arm was bent
a little as i do this i could also elbow
him as i'm coming over if his arm's
extended
i'm simply going to bring my arm over
the top now from here
i'm going to bring my hand right back to
strike mike in the face
this will occupy his hand or he gets hit
in the face one of the two
either thing's good for me so i come
back towards him here boom and i hit him
in the face let's go to the other side
again
so i'm here i move offline i strike
bang from here i'm going to pull one arm
against the other so i'm pulling this
arm
against this one and my free hand is
going to come straight
up hitting in his wrist to knock it free
of my lapel
here's balance is broken i step behind
him and bring him down
draw a bolt of his arms across his body
i catch as i drop my shin on top
i rear up here and my back hands free so
i can use a weapon if i need it
one more time at speed
hey
nugget